are you planning on supporting the
prime-minister steel next week well
let's see what what happens now I think
the good thing about what happened
yesterday is first of all we've got that
final insurance against No Deal and
we've also now going to see this
proposal go straight into bill committee
stage where we can test out and you know
have our final chance to shape brexit
over the coming days because I think the
other thing that was clear about
yesterday is that this deal is now
likely to pass so the coming days the
cut the coming couple of weeks really
are our final chance to shape brexit to
lay down different amendments there'll
be some colleagues who want to lay down
an amendment for a second referendum
others will want to look at that future
relationship and try and shake that
others will want to lay amendments
toughening up the workers rights and
environmental protections that my
colleagues Caroline Flint and Melanie on
got into this agreement so let's see
what comes out the other side now and
that's what we've got to do over the
next few days so notice she's slightly
sidestep the question about whether or
not you're going to be voting for the
deal when it comes back is that because
you're still making your mind up well as
I say I mean let's let's see how things
shape out I mean I probably wouldn't
have voted for it if we'd had a straight
up-and-down vote on it
Oh over the weekend but I do think now
that we've got to move forward we do
have to resolve this issue we have to
resolve brexit even if you're somebody
who is advocating a second referendum
you still need to say what's going to be
on the ballot paper we still need to
have a brexit proposition time is
running out and that might that's why we
we've got to resolve brexit and I've
always thought I think it's been pretty
clear actually that the matters in
Parliament have always been clear that
people didn't want No Deal but the maths
in Parliament have also been there for a
deal for the right kind of deal I would
have preferred a different sort of deal
I would have preferred a much softer
brexit but I'm afraid those
opportunities to shape that brexit worth
watered in previous occasions in the
last few months we had a set of
indicative votes on on lots of versions
of Brack seats we had cross party talks
and unfortunately those on the extremes
of this debate on both sides have
thwarted those efforts so now we're kind
of left with you know some various
suboptimal
options here and we have to make a
judgement about about what the right
thing to do is so I think it's probably
now boiling down to a brexit of this
deal versus a general election and I
would really worry about a general
election when we haven't actually left
the EU I worry about that what that
would do to the Labour Party and the
Labour communities that we represent who
many of whom voted to leave and who were
really angry that we've not actually
respected the outcome of that referendum
so far I mean a couple weeks ago you
signed this letter to the President of
the European Commission along with 18 of
your colleagues and you said if a deal
can be brought back to the Commons in
the coming weeks it avoids a No Deal and
ensures greater certainty during the
UK's departure we believe it serves
Britain's national interest to approve
it I just wonder why if you believe
what's in the letter
you would even consider not backing the
deal because it does take no deal off
the table doesn't it and do you think
that some of your labor labor colleagues
at risk of you know leading us up the
hill a bit hinting that you want to back
a brexit deal but then edging away at
the last minute no we we want there to
be a good deal for Britain and that's
what we were saying in that letter and
actually I think that in part in a very
small part you know maybe those kind of
expressions and and that letter helped
to move on those conversations but it
wasn't a blank check for any deal it
wasn't a blank check for our votes on
anything and as I say we now have over
the coming days the last chance I think
really to shape brexit we've had lots of
chances to shape brexit in the past and
Parliament hasn't been able to come to a
view about the sort of breaks that I was
proposing at that's at that stage you
know a common market solution where we
stayed in the single market but we left
the EU that was rejected by par
as we're all the other options at the
time but now we do have a final chance
because I do think following yesterday
and it's clear from your program this
morning what amber rod was saying in
others that the votes probably are there
now for for a deal so we'll continue to
work as labor colleagues across across
the house and with the labor front bench
to try and shape that deal as best as we
can before the 31st of October it's
interesting you say that you think the
votes are actually there for a deal and
how many of your labor colleagues do you
think they end up supporting it well I
don't I don't know if that will be up to
those labor colleagues but what I would
say is that I found some of the attacks
on on labor colleagues some of the
vilification of Labor colleagues to be
absolutely appalling you know we're
talking about many many labor colleagues
labor constituencies actually not like
mine my seat voted remain but many labor
seats where the vast majority of their
constituents voted to leave and
colleagues are trying to grapple with
these very difficult issues they're
trying to respect the outcome of that
referendum they're trying to respect the
views of their constituents respect the
views of their communities and they're
vilified for doing so and I think that's
something that's got really wrong in in
our politics I mean it shouldn't be an
extreme position should it to say look
we had a referendum the result was
something that I didn't campaign for
that many of us in the Labor Party
didn't campaign for but the result was
what it was which was a huge turnout and
people voted to leave the EU and we have
to try and respect that and you know I'm
talking to you here from Manchester
which is the home of the labor movement
in many ways where the Peterloo massacre
that we've just marked recently took
place where the Chartist movement the
trade union movement the co-operative
movement in fact the first meeting of
the Labor Party was held and what was
that about it was about giving voice
giving power giving representation to
working people in Parliament and in
government and it's many labor community
that voted leave and I really really
worry about was turning our back on
those communities and saying to them I'm
sorry your voice doesn't matter anymore
I'm not gonna represent you the Labour
Party's not going to represent you any
longer because we thought you were wrong
and actually we thought you're a bitty
ill-informed and at times we thought
you're a bit racist and that's why we're
going to ignore what you said and I
really worry about that not just for the
future of our democracy but for the
future of our party and I think that's
why we've got to work really hard now to
try and respect the outcome of the
referendum but shape that brexit deal
get the best possible outcome that we
can over the coming days and then let's
get into that general election on a
strong platform for the Labour Party
just to clarify when you're talking
about the abuse that some of your
colleagues have faced where is this
abuse coming from is it coming from
within the labour party what we've seen
that haven't we we've seen members of
the National Executive we've seen other
colleagues in Parliament saying that any
Labour colleague who could possibly
think about supporting a deal or wanting
to leave the EU are not real socialists
they're not real members that are over
party I mean this is just you know it
appalls me frankly and you know I think
we just all need to say take a step back
here we're all trying to make very
difficult decisions in a complex
scenario that's far from ideal no one
wants to be this I don't want us to
leave the EU ID it's not what I voted
for it's not what I want to see happen
in fact I used to be the director of
Britain in Europe for many years so you
know that's not where I come from but we
are trying to grapple with a set of
suboptimal
options each of which are difficult
there is no easy solution here
even a second referendum which you know
I don't think there still are the votes
in Parliament that's why it wasn't put
to Parliament yesterday even on the day
of the March the vote wasn't put to
Parliament because those advocating a
second referendum know the numbers
aren't there so there's no easy path
here out of the situation that we're in
and that's why it requires compromise it
requires as all coming together and most
of all it requires us all to respect
each others opinions respect each
other's communities and each other's
situation
and respect the fact that we're all
coming at this with with the right
values and with with the future of the
country and the future of our party at
that before